can you share that quick story that you
DM me
um
about that guy that you got introduced
to the billionaire and kind of the story
around it and how it all came from the
one percent oh yeah like the benefit
yeah yeah without yeah without giving
away the details obviously well okay
what I've given away the details and if
you you know if you join rich as rich as
group and you know you you pay up rich
and join the group and you think it's
going to start raining dollars and hot
chicks then they'll join the group
no there is people down below yeah yeah
yeah that people think that's what
happens so we've we started like
business entrepreneur networking within
the one percent group and it's just
literally like throwing out your like
like you know like a baseball card with
all your stats on it just literally
here's what I do here's what I'm capable
of a capability statement and we just
all start swapping them around and you
know and one of the guys from the one
percent here needed a specific computer
uh skill and he posted it in the um
business only chat and within 30 seconds
one guy was like use this guy he's
really good it saved him days of
searching and vetting and I told a
couple of guys what I do and one of the
guys in the group had us do some
investigative research for him and he
happened to be a few weeks later he
happened to be at a very wealthy friend
of his place and he heard him bitching
about some problems he had and he said
well I know someone who can fix problems
and I went and met the guy and then we
you know we gave the guy a proposal and
he's he's hired us now he's a client of
ours he's a fan client and that's that's
just the power of networking which you
know they're not going to teach you in
college and you know people you know
Ward gets out then and people come to
you yeah it's weird that it's like you
know you have to explain the benefit of
of leveraging connections and networks I
mean I've always said like your network
is your net worth but people don't lean
into those things and it's like like
even in my own Community again the links
below it's in the ticker
um a lot of people don't tap into it you
know they don't lean into it it's like
oh I want to join a community and it's
like you know 50 said they think you
know money and and fun and all
all sorts of stuff is going to come you
know raining their way and it's like no
you have to actually integrate you have
to you have to show up you know creating
value and you know as a result of that
you get yourself in a position where you
get picked up at a you know an airport
in a you know exotic car doing xxx
speeds going to a billionaires uh place
to solve his problems right and you know
this is how you you know this is how you
better yourself this is how you improve
is with people
um anybody that's built anything of any
significance relied on other people and
networks to help them do that right
yeah even even last you know a few weeks
ago when we were up in the Colorado
Rockies all skiing and you know a
multi-million dollar home that was owned
by one of the guys in your group yeah
and just 10 minutes sitting in the
kitchen I got more better Financial
advice than I'd gotten in five years
that was a good trip man I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full-length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out